well there's a new horror movie trailer
out for the first time in a while
so just for old times sake if you want
to hear the meaning behind this
then stick around to the end of this
video
freaky is the new horror comedy from
director christopher landon who is
probably most known for making the happy
death day movies
this is kind of a perfect project for
him because happy death day is basically
groundhog day if it had a serial killer
and freaky is basically freaky friday
that had a serial killer
okay so i was never the most popular
homecomings this weekend
booker is gonna be at the dance and boys
never really noticed me wait what
no i don't buy that for a second i mean
we're talking about catherine newton
here we're talking about lucy stevens
herself she's cute as hell
interesting fact by the way her and
director christopher landon are both
alumni of the paranormal activity
franchise
yeah you're right that's not that
interesting but i do give the director
points for implementing creative and
creepy school mascots in his movies
showing off a little bit of his
directorial trademark there
also having clever slogans for those
teams but the big homage here other than
freaky friday and happy death day is
seen in this part where the killer
chases down the girl with some kind of
magically activated knife and suddenly
stormy clouds and lightning fill the
skies as some kind of ritual is
performed the result of which is the
killer's soul being transferred into the
girl and vice versa
the theatrics are almost exactly the
same as what's seen in child's play
which also features a serial killer
using a ritual to transfer his soul into
another body
albeit a much stubbier one in child's
play the killer
discovers he has a limited amount of
time to transfer his soul back into a
human vessel before he gets stuck inside
the doll forever and it seems like
freaky follows those same rules
i have like less than six hours to swap
back or i'm gonna be stuck in his body
forever i also noticed the killer who is
known as the blissful butcher wears a
mask
it looks like a re-dead math from the
legend of zelda ocarina of time which is
closely related to something called the
gibdo mask which allows you to blend in
with re-deads and gibdos undetected just
as the blissful butcher can blend in
with his victims undetected
while inside millie's body maybe
there'll be a scene where she does the
same thing and uses her new body to
slide in with criminals just as link
uses various masks to gain access to
places in majora's mask it also bears a
pretty close resemblance to the jason
mask from friday the 13th
in any event even if that's not an
intentional reference i do remember
christopher landon saying that he wanted
to bring back the idea of the mass
serial killer with happy death day and
with that series potentially dead
no pun intended it's good to see him
continuing it in another form
pun intended that time because millie
takes on another form
don't know what's going on here but yeah
that's the end of the trailer friday the
13th
because that's spooky day but let's be
real this thing's not gonna be in
theaters in november
my theory is that movie studios keep
putting release dates in the pandemic
because when that date comes and they
inevitably have to delay its people
report on it and they get free press
that being said i wouldn't mind watching
this one on my tv in november but hey
we'll see what happens
click the video on the left to see my
things you missed episode on happy death
day and if you love horror subscribe to
this channel right now
i'm not asking i've got new horrors
every week so ring that death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we stay inside
you